I believe the best thing this new  Republican house can do for our country  Democrats and Republicans to restore  trust is we got to have election  Integrity to such an extent that the  American people can believe in the  process they have very real reasons not  to believe in it I don't know who won or  who Biden was declared the winner I  don't want to relitigate all of that but  the fact is a lot of people don't think  that was a fair game do I believe uh  fraud exists vote fraud and cheating and  elections I know it as a fact coming out  of Chicago politics I also know it it's  been at six years in Congress and  hearing stories about the Democrats from  Philadelphia and Detroit and other big  cities now do Republicans steal votes in  places where they control uh polling the  apparatus I'm sure they do it's human  nature we've got to fix this system